so if you're like me as a middle eastern
Alex I'm naturally super skeptical I'm a
paranoid guy I don't trust a lot of
people okay I'm kind of like well what's
the guy's motive
etc etc I think what people want is to
listen to other skeptical people I think
Joe's skeptical I don't look at Joe and
I'm like you know Joe is a a guy that's
fully trying to push an agenda I think
Joe Sanders said guys I don't know
what's going on here I'm going through
the product like the way you opened up
skeptical and he is curious I love the
way he's very curious I love the way he
opened up the RFK interview whereas I'm
not gonna lie to you for the last five
years you know when I would watch
sometimes this guy's a cook this guy's
this I'm like okay probably not and then
all of a sudden I'm like wait a minute
some of the stuff he's saying is true
and then I read the book and I'm like
holy